that's some traumatic ptsd right there
slamming a book
it's nice a teacher actually found a
practical use for a textbook
[Music]
hi i'm nicholas ceroni i'm in my 18th
year as a high school history and
cultural studies teacher
my name is selani they call me miss
tsunami i'm a teacher
i've been teaching for about four plus
years actually five or six years what am
i talking about time has gone by i'm in
a zone
i'm in my second year as a tick-tock
teacher and i only have a tick tock
because one of my students
junior madrid so shout out to junior
encouraged me to get it
and now i kind of have a stronger
following than he does so we have
battles back and forth on tick tock
i try to hide my tick tocks for my
students but i love tick tock i think
it's a great place to go
and dive in and get lost in the nonsense
so first video let's see
this is this is excessive the haircut
and
and the uniform probably happened to him
in the military a lot
got the book
that's some traumatic ptsd right there
slamming a book
it's nice a teacher actually found a
practical use for a textbook
that's pretty traumatic what i do if a
student falls asleep
is i have everyone in my class quietly
leave the classroom and then when they
wake up they instantly
run out of the classroom thinking
they're late to their next class and
we're all in the hallway just deploying
which one what's the longest river in
the world
what's the longest river in the world we
always try to guide our students
what year the louisiana purchase was
what year what's the largest and deepest
ocean what's an ocean
now which one is the largest and deepest
think about that ah yeah that's not me
during tests but i do ask questions
i won't repeat the same thing over and
over because they're just gonna look at
me like
miss tsunami what are you talking about
[Music]
i do make a lot of sounds or i'll talk
to myself especially virtual teaching
i will be talking to myself most
teachers either have a teacher look
a teacher voice which is what i'm using
right now
or if you're good you have both i hope i
don't make that many sounds
oh my god oh my god
oh my god yeah nobody wants to wake up
in class with their professor all by
themselves no one no one no one i've had
that happen in college
i'll be honest i know my student is the
first one to sign on they're kind of
awkward so they'll sign on real quick
see it's just me and turn off their
camera because especially if you didn't
like the teacher
and you didn't have something to talk
about they're probably going to talk
about mr ferroni like cultural studies
or history
no we could talk about a lot of stuff
i'm timothy chapman i'm a third year
management and economics major and i'm
currently
tearing up the stuff wow
wow
great class today no apparently not all
right well
have fun try not to catch cove but again
or for the first time or whatever can't
be can't be mad at him
oh my god i am not mad at him listen i
might be teaching class from tahiti i
don't know
i've had students sit in their car with
me coming from class i've had a student
in a chair that they were leaning back
and i'm like where are you and they were
at the dentist office i was flattered
that they did not want to miss class so
they were sitting in literally the
dentist chair
with me i did have a student today who
asked me politely if he could leave
class a few minutes early because he's
in pennsylvania
paintballing so that was fun i thought
it'd be funny if he actually would have
me
on camera with class while he was
running around playing paintball
i'm flattered you're at work you're
doing something you still want to be in
my class
thank you i have had students doing
classroom weird locations i think a
couple of kids went on vacation
just turkey or something like that and
they checked in
but it looked so crazy i was like
wait wait where are you
[Laughter]
i love that movie that was og y'all know
about that
what is your roommate doing
[Music]
i'm more impressed that they know the
bueller reference you'll see people walk
behind doing stuff
i've had a few shirtless parents but
yeah i've had a couple students like try
to sneak onto the camera because they
have pajamas on or like they'll do
something weird and i'm like
i literally see you like i know this has
been very challenging
these videos always get me
[Music]
and again most people don't realize you
know as as teachers uh
we care so much about what we do my
students did something similar here and
i was so impressed not only that they
did it but they were able to coordinate
20-something students who normally would
not have their cameras on and each wrote
a letter and kind of shared their
their love and their gratitude i i print
them out i have a little happy folder i
put all the emails and notes and letters
from students to because
that's what we look at when we're
questioning our our existence
as educators okay here we go
seriously is it like is it my fault that
you have your cameras off
so nice
[Music]
with your cameras off
[Music]
more nice stuff you guys the world is
already crazy so all the nice videos you
guys do with the signs and everything
that's
awesome i think you guys should do more
of that stuff and make more funny videos
of course
actually as i'm looking off screen i
have i've framed a framed let me grab it
[Music]
this is what we do with the stuff you
give us this is a framed post-it note
that one of my students
who i literally thought hated my guts
the entire year left on my desk
at the end of the year we battled every
single day and every single day i told
her i'm not going to give up on you and
you could
yell at me all you want but i'm here for
you and i know you're going through a
tough time and she was going through a
really tough time and the last day of
school when none of my students were
there she was
so as she left she she said i left you
something in your desk
and this is what she left me and said hi
mr ferroni you're the best don't ever
forget that you always look out for
people you're loving you're caring
and i'm so thankful for you and this is
what we do with the notes you give us so
stuff like that is always worth it it is
it is never too early to thank a teacher
who made an impact on your life